what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel um today i'm
gonna be talking about what i've seen in
dating dynamics before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that we are
going to be notified of my daily videos
again if you guys have watched three or
more of my videos to their entirety and
you have not subscribed to me and you
have beef
beef okay
um okay but also you're gonna have to
bear with me because
i'm on vacation with my family so a lot
of these videos are gonna be very like
unscripted and just me talking to the
camera
so yeah um okay so
in the middle sphere
i see a lot of guys put everything into
an equation
so
they'll say oh i'm in the top this
percent of height i'm in the top this
percent of
you know income i'm in the top this
percent of my weight or whatever or my
fitness you know top 10 top 20 why can't
why don't these women want me like i'm
clearly out of their league
um
and this is just coming from a woman's
point of view and to men they really a
lot of times they don't understand it
but
a lot of times girls will take chemistry
and like connection with a guy over like
the on paper guy that's you know better
and
i think that's why a lot of times girls
make really bad you know we as women
don't always make the best dating
decisions because
our emotions get into it and we look for
chemistry so
if you're talking to a girl and you're
wondering like why did she pick that guy
he i have this this this this and this
she should pick me
well
it's probably
something to do with chemistry and
common interests and i've even seen this
on the guys side like
there was a guy in college that picked
like a different girl over me right and
on paper i would have like in the man of
spheres perspective i would have been
the better pick like i had i was a
virgin um i had
i would say i was more attractive than
her but you know
i'm not gonna like show pictures
but you know he had more in common with
her they had a better connection and
sometimes guys that's just life like you
don't
win things on paper oh and like she was
her butt was like all over the internet
i did not move like that but
i don't know guys like sometimes people
pick connection
and no matter how much you study like
dating dynamics no matter how much you
study
what percent of
you know income earners you are what
percent of
fitness you are no matter how much you
work on yourself you can't fake
connection
and common interests and like values
with people
so let me know in the comments what you
guys think don't forget to subscribe to
the channel bring my notification bell i
will talk to you guys next time